USA Today Washington bureau chief Susan
page joins us now so good morning Susan
good morning there is a furious back and
forth between the White House the
publisher and author Michael wolf
Michael wolf is standing by his
reporting this morning he said the
president has quote lost it who has the
upper hand here Susan well I think that
you know that those that storm coverage
you just showed on the unnies Coast that
is nothing compared to what's going on
inside the White House in response to
this book because this book is a very
serious development for the White House
it's got all these gossipy details but
more seriously there's evidence in there
there are reports in the book that go to
the Russia investigation could have
legal repercussions and there's also as
chip was saying the portrait of a
president in the White House that is
really quite dysfunctional so you would
say the White House is on defense at
this moment yes I think the White House
is on defense and one of the things that
is I think alarming for the White House
is that this now they've written these
negative stories about how the
president's function is being impulsive
and reckless and uninformed in the past
from Democrats from anonymous sources
that's been a consistent theme of
coverage of the president but now we
have on the record quotes from the
president's most senior and closest
advisors that go to how the White House
works or doesn't work but Susan there's
also an issue about whether some of
these comments were actually off the
record I wonder if you can talk about
that a little bit and Michael Wolfe says
in the introduction of the book this is
a version I believe to be true is that
problematic in any way well it is and we
don't know that everything reported in
this book is true but I do think it's
notable that there's been pushed back to
the weather things were off the record
not to whether they were sad there's
pushback to attacks on Michael Wolfe and
on Steve Bannon but they don't go to the
substance of the content of the book
there's been less pushback on that and
that is what in Washington we might call
a kind of form of confirmation I want to
talk about some of the more serious
charges that are outlined in the New
York Times today that deal with the
investigation in by the Special Counsel
Robert Muller the New York Times has
some incredible detailing in this
reporting and I just want to read you
and I know you've read the report
Michael Schmitt in The New York time
but the Special Counsel has received
handwritten notes from mr. Trump's
former chief of staff Reince Priebus
showing that mr. Trump talked to mr.
Priebus about how he called mr. Comey to
urge him to say publicly that he was not
under investigation and then the New
York Times is reporting that even some
of President Trump's own White House
lawyers tried to took the extraordinary
step of misleading mr. Trump about
whether he had the authority to remove
him his own lawyers you know we what's
the lesson from the Watergate
investigation from the Whitewater
investigation and more it said often the
big problems arise for a White House not
from a crime but from a cover-up and the
this New York Times report goes straight
to that point about whether there were
efforts by the president in the White
House to obstruct the FBI investigation
and there's also evidence in this in
this reporting this morning that
reinforces the arguments the allegations
that James Comey made the fired FBI
director that the White House and the
president have denied and called lies
all right Susan page thank you